we've seen a lot of 3d here at CES for
the past few years but nothing quite
like this here we have cassia's 3d
painting technology basically it takes a
2d image and transforms it into a 3d
piece of art which you can have poking
out from your wall it uses cassia's
high-speed processing to turn your image
into digital data you could have your
own kitten in a tree or even a demon dog
personally I'm going to get a picture of
my cat lelu done like this we don't know
how much this is going to cost but it's
probably going to be pretty expensive
casio is trying to gauge interest in
consumers in buying this technology
though so if you'd like to have a piece
of art poking out of your wall you
should let casiano